this council was convened today
to discuss the implementation of the
minsk agreements
a goal that we all share
despite russia's persistent violations
these agreements which were negotiated
in 2014 and 2015 and signed by russia
remain the basis
for the peace process to resolve the
conflict in eastern ukraine
this council's primary responsibility
the very reason for its creation
is the preservation of peace and
security
as we meet today
the most immediate threat to peace and
security
is russia's looming aggression against
ukraine
the stakes go far beyond ukraine
this is a moment of peril for the lives
and safety of millions of people
as well as for the foundation of the
united nations charter
and the rules-based international order
that preserves stability worldwide
this crisis directly affects
every member of this council
and every country in the world
because the basic principles that
sustain peace and security
principles that were enshrined in the
wake of two world wars and a cold war
are under threat
the principle that
one country cannot change the borders of
another by force
the principle that one country cannot
dictate another's choices or policies or
with whom it will associate
the principle of national sovereignty
this is the exact kind of crisis that
the united nations
and specifically
this security council
was created to prevent
we must address what russia is doing
right now
to ukraine
over the past months
without provocation or justification
russia has amassed more than a hundred
and fifty thousand troops around
ukraine's borders
in russia belarus
occupied crimea
russia says it's drawing down those
forces
we do not see that happening on the
ground
our information indicates clearly that
these forces
including ground troops aircraft ships
are preparing to launch an attack
against ukraine
in the coming days
we don't know precisely
how things will play out
but here's what the world can expect to
see unfold
in fact it's unfolding right now
today
as russia takes steps down the path to
war
and reissued the threat of military
action
first russia plans to manufacture a
pretext for its attack
this could be a violent event that
russia will bring on ukraine or an
outrageous accusation that russia will
level against the ukrainian government
we don't know exactly the form it will
take
it could be a fabricated so-called
terrorist bombing inside russia
the invented discovery of a mass grave
a staged drone strike against civilians
or a fake
even a real
attack using chemical weapons
russia may describe this event as ethnic
cleansing
or a genocide
making a mockery of a concept that we in
this chamber do not take lightly nor do
i take lightly based on my family
history
in the past few days
russian media has already begun to
spread some of these false alarms
and claims
to maximize public outrage to lay the
groundwork for an invented justification
for war
today
that drum beat has only intensified in
russia's state-controlled media
we've heard some of these basic
allegations from russian-backed speakers
here today
second
in response to this manufactured
provocation
the highest levels of the russian
government
may theatrically convene emergency
meetings to address the so-called crisis
the government will issue proclamations
declaring that mushroom must respond to
defend russian citizens or ethnic
russians in ukraine
next
the attack is planned to begin
russian missiles and bombs will drop
across ukraine
communications will be jammed
cyber attacks will shut down key
ukrainian institutions
after that
russian tanks and soldiers will advance
on key targets that have already been
identified and mapped out in detailed
plans
we believe these targets include
russia's capital ukraine's capital kiev
a city of 2.8 million people
and conventional attacks
are not all that russia plans to inflict
upon the people of ukraine
we have information that indicates
russia will target specific groups of
ukrainians
we've been warning the ukrainian
government of all that is coming
and here today
we are laying it out in great detail
with the hope that by sharing what we
know with the world
we can influence russia to abandon the
path of war
and choose a different path
while there's still time
now
i'm mindful that
some have called into question our
information
recalling previous instances where
intelligence ultimately did not bear out
but let me be clear
i am here today
not to start a war
but to prevent one
the information i presented here
is validated by what we've seen
unfolding in plain sight
before our eyes for months
and remember that while russia has
repeatedly derided our warnings and
alarms as melodrama and nonsense
they have been steadily amassing more
than 150 000 troops on ukraine's borders
as well as the capabilities to conduct a
massive military assault
it isn't just us seeing this
allies and partners see the same thing
and russia hasn't only been hearing from
us
the international chorus
has grown louder and louder
if russia doesn't invade ukraine
then we will be relieved
that russia changed course
and proved our predictions wrong
that would be a far better outcome than
the course we're currently on
and we'll gladly accept any criticism
that anyone directs at us
as president biden said
this would be a war of choice
and if russia makes that choice
we've been clear
along with allies and partners that our
response will be sharp
and decisive
president biden reiterated that
forcefully earlier this week
there's another choice russia can still
make
if there's any truth to its claim
that is committed to diplomacy
diplomacy is the only responsible way to
resolve this crisis
an essential part of this is through
implementation of the minsk agreements
the subject of our session today
there are series of commitments that
russia and ukraine made under minsk
with the osce and the normandy format
partners involved as well
if russia is prepared to sit with the
ukrainian government
and work through the process of
implementing these commitments
our friends in france and germany stand
ready to convene senior level
discussions in the normandy format
to settle these issues
ukraine is ready for this
and we stand fully ready to support the
parties
progress toward resolving the donbass
crisis through the minsk agreements
can reinforce the broader discussions on
security issues that we're prepared to
engage in with russia in coordination
with our allies and partners
more than three weeks ago
we provided russia with a paper
that detailed concrete reciprocal steps
that we can take in the near term
to address our respective concerns
and advance the collective security
interests of russia
the united states
and our european partners and allies
this morning we received a response
which we're evaluating
earlier today i sent a letter to
russia's foreign minister sergey lavrov
proposing that we meet next week in
europe
following on our talks in recent weeks
to discuss the steps that we can take to
resolve this crisis without conflict
we're also proposing meetings of the
nato-russia council
and the osce permanent council
these meetings can
pave the way for a summit of key leaders
in the context of de-escalation
to reach understandings on our mutual
security concerns
as lead diplomats for our nations we
have a responsibility to make every
effort for diplomacy to succeed
to leave no diplomatic stone unturned
if russia is committed to diplomacy
we're presenting every opportunity for
it to demonstrate that commitment
i have no doubt that
the response to my remarks here today
will be more dismissals from the russian
government about the united states
stoking hysteria or that it has no plans
to invade ukraine
so let me make this simple
the russian government can announce
today
with no qualification equivocation or
deflection
that russia will not invade ukraine
state it clearly
stated plainly to the world
and then demonstrate it
by sending your troops
your tanks your planes
back to their barracks and hangers and
sending your diplomats to the
negotiating table
in the coming days
the world will remember that commitment
or
the refusal to make it
i yield the floor